- Okay, so, I am much older
than my coworker Eric,
but sometimes that just
means I'm much wiser.
For example, Eric thought:
Say what you just said again.
- Paris Hilton invented the selfie.
- She didn't invent the selfie.
- Oh my God, yes.
Look, look.
Huh? Huh?
Eleven years ago today.
- [Sarah] Okay.
- [Eric] Paris Hilton and
Britney invented the selfie.
There, they're taking the selfie.
- But in 2004, the movie
"13 Going on 30" came out,
and that movie has a scene
where they take a selfie.
- I've never even heard of
that movie, so I doubt it.
- Hold on. I'm going to show it to you.
- [Eric] That's a camera though.
- [Sarah] That's like
a selfie from 2004, so.
- I was doing work and now
you got me invested in this,
and I need to know like who actually
invented the first selfie.
- I'm gunna find out.
- I need you to find this.
- Ten minutes, baby.
- I'm going to watch this movie for now.
- Wait, you're watching the movie?
- Ya, it seems really good, to be honest.
(upbeat techno music)
- I had to find out who
invented the selfie.
I mean I work at BuzzFeed, so
it's like my job to do that.
It's not my job to do that specifically,
but I made it my job, today at least.
So, I called BuzzFeed's
resident selfie expert.
Hey, Jazz!
- Taking selfies is like really important
to make sure that you're
confident when you do it
because, you know, everybody's
going to be seeing this.
You want to make sure you
find some good lighting.
- Okay, so who?
- And like it's always good if you like
match your background, or like contrast
with your background, you know,
like play off the colors.
- So who invented the selfie?
- I would assume Paris
Hilton, but I'm not sure.
- That's not who really invented it.
Like who really invented the
selfie, like the first person?
- Is that what you wanted
to know the whole time?
You could literally just Google it.
Just go on, type on your little keyboard,
"Who invented the selfie"?
- So I decided to Google it.
Turns out, there's not
really a definitive answer,
at least not on the first like two pages
of my Google search results.
Not only did Paris
Hilton have nothing to do
with inventing the selfie,
she didn't even coin the term.
The first documented use
of the term "selfie,"
at least, in print,
was in September 2002
when a user "Hopey" posted
a close-up of his busted lip, writing,
"I had a hole about one centimeter long,
right through my bottom lip.
And sorry about the
focus, it was a selfie."
Christian, did you see my slack?
It's the first selfie.
Cool, right?
- That's not a selfie.
- It doesn't look like
a selfie as we know it,
but it's just the lips, but it's still.
- Okay, so, Hopey himself says,
"It was not a word I coined.
It's something that was just
common slang at the time,
used to describe a picture of yourself."
- Okay, well then who coined the term?
- Coining it is different
than inventing it.
Think about it.
Like artists for centuries
were doing self portraits,
since like before the 1500s.
- Should have paid attention in art class.
According to James Hall,
people in the 15th century
were manipulating their self-images,
sometimes making
themselves appear younger,
and sometimes casting
themselves in biblical roles
because branding is, after all,
the second oldest profession.
More so than, Hopey's busted lip,
these self portraits with
their manipulated images
capture the spirit of the selfie.
Albrecht Durer, a self-portraitist
and a well known narcissist,
used to paint himself
with long, flowing hair
to appear more Christ like,
although his actual
appearance is more reminiscent
of a guy from the early 90s
with over-plucked eyebrows
and permed hair, but honestly,
what's wrong with a little
selfie manipulation?
When I post a selfie, my teeth are white,
my eyes are big, and my nose
is practically non-existent.
I'm basically a Bratz doll.
Rembrandt, Courbet, Van Gogh,
they all painted selfies.
Sadly, a few hours into
the middle of my research,
I hit a bit of a snag.
It's between Rembrandt,
Courbet, and Van Gogh.
- Before you do that,
we have to figure out
if like paintings are selfies.
Like have you looked at a
definition of what a selfie is?
- Ya, I looked at, of course
I looked the definition.
- So, what did it say?
- I didn't look at a definition.
- Alright, so let's look up
the definition real quick.
- Alright, good.
- According to Oxford it
is a photograph that one
has taken of oneself, typically
with a smartphone or webcam
and uploaded to a social media website.
- A selfie has to be a photo.
Everything I've done to this
point has been pointless.
- How much time did you put into this?
- We're going to have
to time travel forward
a couple hundred years to
the invention of the camera.
The first partially successful
images were produced
around 1816 by Nicéphore Niépce,
but those negatives didn't even last long.
He used silver chloride,
which darkens when exposed to light.
Those images disappeared.
He was basically the
19th century SnapChat.
So, we can't really say for
sure whether Nicéphore Niépce
took that that first selfie
because we don't have the photos anymore.
The Library of Congress believes
the first selfie taken in America
was a photographic portrait
by Robert Cornelius in 1839.
Robert had to hold still for 15 minutes
to get the perfect selfie,
which is not too different
than how long it takes
to get the perfect selfie today,
since we take like 80 photos
on average, maybe 100.
Come here.
- You got the answer?
- Ya, come here.
That's my main man, Robert C. from Philly,
and he took the first selfie in America,
and that's it right there.
- Where's the camera?
- Well he had to like set it,
and then he had to run around and go.
Selfie sticks, that was not a thing.
- He used an Instagram
filter and like took credit
for inventing the selfie.
- [Sarah] He didn't.
- It's called a colloidal wet plate.
- That's the filter?
- Paris Hilton is not even
the first celeb selfie
because Anastasia Romanov
took that in 1914.
- [Christian] Is that a duck face?
- So, she invented the selfie?
- Rob from Philly invented the selfie.
- Ya, well I wouldn't say he invented
the selfie either because actually.
The selfie isn't really an
invention; it's a phenomenon.
The inventor isn't a particular person,
it's the Internet, social media,
our own vain narcissistic selves.
And goddammit, we don't want
to waste our time waiting
for someone else to take it.
We can take the photo our God damn selves.
So, who invented the selfie?
It's you; you invented the selfie.
- No, no, stop.
I don't want it.
I didn't invent the selfie.
I don't want to start any drama.
- Like capital "you."
- The greater sense of "you."
- Yes, ya, thank you.
Like, ya, humanity, we all did together.
It's like a phenomenon; it's not a person.
- Is that the ending of this,
is you just copping out?
- It felt deep when I wrote it.
- This is for a video?
- Ya, it's for a video.
- We are running out of ideas.
- Oh my God.
I guess I didn't really
answer the question.
- [Eric] I just made 20
bucks off of Bitcoin.
(dramatic music)